prego life penso che ci siamo ci sei non
forse ancora non si è connesso vediamo
un minuto di colore in atto di ciò ci
vedete che vediamo allora cosa faremo ci
giocheremo ad among us assieme in
diretta siccome si chiedete sempre di
giocare assieme in diretta finalmente
facciamo la diretta che vuoi allora
vedevi state tutti arrivando alle sue
continue e pestaggi riesca a leggerli
tutti allora scrive the sun lasciato se
riuscite a sentirci e vederci bene così
siamo subito il volo chiamo se va tutto
bene vediamo appunto leggendo i vostri
messaggi
scrivete si sentite bene se vedete bene
così fra poco possiamo iniziare con il
codice voi mi raccomando dovete stare
super attenti apprende il codice è
metterlo su un gas per giocare con noi
perché purtroppo lo sapete
dieci sono le persone massime allora sta
leggendo i commenti
allora vicente vi vedo ok si sentite
bene ci vedete bene se qualche ritardo
ma se qualcosa che emozione
diretta allora ok allora funziona tutto
benissimo allora come sono le regole di
questo gioco facciamo le partite
standard di among us
però però senno e capitiamo impostori
ovviamente voi non sapete è sì posate
subito perché ovviamente lo vedete dalla
dalla diretta quindi se noi capitiamo
impostori giochiamo invece a nascondino
quindi se noi siamo impostori noi
dobbiamo trovare crew mail increment
devono nascondersi non possono però
chiamare le emergenze di meeting non
possono appunto vuotare l'impostore
perché sapete già chi è l'impostore è
l'obiettivo è finire voi le tasche senza
essere trovati dall'impostare questo
solo se noi capitiamo impostori quindi
cesto luni margins i meeting all'inizio
in quanto bisogna dire chi sono i
giocatori ovviamente oltre anno perché
questi giorni sarà comunque diretta li
vediamo non c'è non c'è bisogno di
emergency meeting fa dopo che ti trovo
emozionati
allora tutti gli altri messaggi sono
tantissimi
allora stiamo ci stiamo ad un bel fucsia
un bel po di persone si sono già
quindi direi che possiamo iniziare il
colle sempre state un bel mi piace
passata perché se questa live raggiunge
i 30 mila mi piace non prossima
settimana faremo un'altra live qui
giochiamo e quindi spogli trasportate io
vi vedo adesso stati bravissimi
bravissimi astori spero li stai non
visto invito su instagram andate a
seguirmi stasera pubblicherò una nuova
foto su instagram
e se voi avete partecipato qua alla live
andate a scrivere sotto la foto che
pubblicherò basterà io
nella live io le rispondo al commento
quindi però ancora non l'ho pubblicata
da pubblicare società adesso allora
leggiamo velocissimamente qualche
commento poi con la partita e voi dovete
stare super attenti a mettere il codice
mi raccomando allora commenti siete
supero emozionati
qualcuno di voi ha già giocato con noi
wow ho lasciato stupiti sui viaggi e
brave di ok di bra direi che possiamo
iniziare devo cominciare aveva partito
allora vai creiamo la partita allora
facciamo tre impostori che bello eccoci
qua allora il codice ragazzi il codice q
zdf hf voi lo vedete nella live qua
vediamo se riuscite a vederlo sto
vedendo i vostri commenti
si dia un po comunque sicuramente fra
poco arriva una cosa che vi voglio
chiedere che chi partecipa alla partita
adesso di lasciare la possibilità anche
ai prossimi ci pare cioè quindi ora voi
che siete qua ora in questa partita
siamo già in dieci
se potete poi una volta finita la
partita allacciarla non fare il replay
comunque lasciarla così possono
partecipare anche gli altri così e docg
anche per gli altri troviamo la
possibilità anche agli altri
alcuni magari tolgono le persone vorrà
partecipare gli altri però mi dispiace
appunto togliere le persone quindi per
favore e poi alla prossima partita
lasciatela così anche gli altri possono
partecipare ok siamo pronti siamo pronti
si parte allora dobbiamo fondino vediamo
quindi facciamo una partita normale
semplice
andiamo subito a fare la nostra palestra
con 20 nel frattempo sono
emozionatissimo io non ce l'ho fatta
nobili caso infatti ogni volta a me
risorse tantissimo che mi scrivete che
non ce la fate a partecipare perché mi
dispiace vorrei farvi partecipare tutti
appunto però purtroppo sono dieci
persone spero che con un aggiornamento
perché ho letto che ci sarà un
suggerimento di hubble gas
spero che faranno che si possa far marin
20 30 sarebbe bellissimo comunque
vediamo le stiamo facendo le tasche tipo
stesse qualche qualche sas limpido
siccome siamo in diretta a un corpo ma
voi nei commenti potete scriverci se
pensate che io sia qualche sachs
vediamo vediamo che cosa dicono in admin
on line al progetto ti ho visto che
arrivata subito l'ira di chi non
riportando navigation l'ha riportato
viola un po staff viola vuoi che dio ea
voi che dite scriveteci nei commenti
allora vediamo voi insospettate scrivete
pure chi sospetta maggior parte a
scappato a noi che io cosa abbiamo fatto
non ho fatto in tempo
ci sono ancora tre impostori trasmodato
che peggiorano altrimenti dobbiamo
vincere
quando leggo anche un po di commenti non
ho in sagra un no non vi preoccupate per
intero ancora dice qui ora che stiamo in
diretta il codice lo mettiamo la quando
lo sono quando non stiamo in diretta
instagram il codice non ho fatto in
tempo neanche avere ghiera rosso panna
no beh il bene chiaro agli impostori
vedono la nostra riunione in diretta
abbiamo ti votano secondo me il ruolo
votare subito rossini e chi sono gli
altri poterti vedere se allora
sicuramente rosso impostore perché si fa
pietà guarda celeste ha di nuovo fatto a
capirlo è la prima visto che il live
[Musica]
allora se un'altra cosa che non avevo
pensato
sei gli impostori si fanno fuori voi lo
vedete in live
quindi nonostante voi avete visto in
live fiera l'impostore si è rotto hanno
comunque mi devi portare non è possibile
rischio va beh allora crew messo
ascoltatemi bene anche voi che non fa
che partecipando al gioco quando vedete
che successe in realtà e gli impostori
non gli conviene molto allora seconda
partita si porta via spero che avete
hanno qualcuno ha lasciato il gioco
moratti è un momento prima di iniziare
così voi che avete già dell'apertura far
questo ci potete please lasciare il
posto a qualcun altro così anche gli
altri possono partecipare come si fa
entrare state scrivendo i commenti dai
opera grazie grazie grazie che sta
uscendo così parti sono pronti gli altri
grazie allora sto vedendo i vostri
commenti
come posso entrare allora bisogna
aspettare appunto che qualcuno nasa del
foschi ha già giocato la sat è imposto
agli altri please perché però poverini
ci rimangono male anche loro vogliono
partecipare
iniziamo fra pochissimo abbiamo anche
scoperto che per impostare si fa fuori
peggio per lui perché non per impostare
questo saremo imposto di noi sicuramente
siamo imposti noi giochiamo a nascondino
quindi pronti a 54 32 rabbia
vediamo un po qualcuno lascia il gioco
perché allora abbiamo visto a nascondino
spero che tutti lo nasconde
magari chiarle emergency meeting che
diciamo impostori siamo rosa celeste
giallo rosa celeste giallo dobbiamo a
noi non lo possiamo chiamare emergenti
meeting bye bye bye chiamato consensi
meeting ok a ok quindi questa sarà molto
interessante questa mattina story due
putti rosa celeste giallo le regole
giochiamo a nascondino scrivi si bravo
formento giochiamo a nascondino uno
screening non si possono riportare gli
impostori però noi dobbiamo cercare e i
più mezza si devono nascondere
ok pronti noi sappiamo che abbiamo
stipato grande con due sono gestibili
piloti hanno solo nono sono caduto il
sistema ok allora possiamo salvarci e
mezzo
che noia nasconditi chi non si nasconde
peggio per noi perché non troverà
l'impostore ok
iniziamo a cercare i crew waits iniziavo
io so anche leggendo i vostri c'è un
nome da sconti perché noi a volte
nascondere ok
iniziamo via qui non c'è nessuno
allora vediamo tutta se troviamo mentre
mi faccio botto la rai tanto non c'è la
paura che qualcuno si vedono uscire
dalle botole perché stanno chi stiamo
cerchiamo anche dallo stato non mischia
[Musica]
wow incredibile
allora per chi ha partecipato questa
partita potete uscire così lasciato il
posto a qualcun altro
vediamo cosa state scrivendo qual è il
codice sto tremando cercare i codici con
dentro un giorno no lo più già da allora
il codice è kourou detta di fhm lo
potete vedere qua sotto
art e però siamo già 10 chi è già
partecipato uscite vive noveau e
gravitava lì si faccia uscite uscite
uscite così lasciato il posto a gli
altri dai ragazzi lasciato il posto agli
altri lo so che volete sempre giocare
con noi e vi divertite è comunque a
giocare con noi anche live però lasciato
erboso agli altri buu berini stanno
aspettando sia un sacco di gente che sta
aspettando a me fa ridere berlin berlino
che sangio casinò sia una bella giornata
del fuori che si sta divertendo
allora iniziamo non ci posso credere in
via 43
vediamo se stiamo ancora impostori
ancora nascondino
invece se siamo primi sul gioco normale
vediamo storie ok nasconde vi nascondete
ha scoperto che dobbiamo fare
l'emergency meeting in cui di samson
impostori così primis possono scappare e
nascondersi via con emergency meeting di
bravi mi dice il codice allora è il
codice adesso no perché abbiamo già
iniziato la partita dopo ok pronti con
vai qui allora impostori rosanero era il
pancione e giochiamo con di rho quindi
stipate schifate tutti e preparatevi a
nascondere la mano ci hanno votato a noi
perché pur avendo messo nascondetevi
nascondetevi nascondetevi allora che
figo non entrare mi dispiace per me che
non riesco a entrare veramente mi
dispiace vai vai andiamo a prendere a
prendere piume nascosto un andre hanno
eliminato o bottino eliminando tutti i
velocisti rossi abbiamo già visto che
vanno spuntino contributori è
facilissimo vincere allora chi ha
giocato uscite ucciderli uscite ok
alessia se uscite vi saluto è vero che
vedono il nome liti quindi ciao alessia
grazie per essere usciti avere lasciato
la scossa agli altri sei partite vi
saluto perché vedo il nome così lasciate
spazio anche agli altri non chi chi chi
appena entrato no ovviamente
grazie di grazie della charles f r
design grazie poi chi è che ha già
partecipato a entrare allora qua nei
commenti state impazzendo chi ha giocato
troppo e troppo affollato e da ora che
cerco di entrare
allora chi è entrato adesso ovviamente
problema
però chi ha già giocato uscite please
lasciate lo spazio anche agli altri dai
ok pronti vediamo è la prima volta che
il gioco di se non riscontrare dovete
avere un po di pazienza
sì allora mi state chiedendo perché è
privato e privato perché sennò entrano
anche altre persone che non sono voi
della live quindi altre persone spero
avete lasciato mi piace la7 mi piace vai
che io vi vedo adesso si faccia avanti
vediamo un po se sarà ancora aziende
rockumentary mac così aiutiamo tutti
quanti a fare le tasche il giallo
marrone e rosa
ok adesso emergenti mi ascoltate di no
ma forse non c'è bisogno di emergency
meeting perché sono poi tutti quanti
tornano intorno al tavolo così si
possono nascondere come devono sapere
che li pone giusta ragione perché magari
non stanno portando quindi giallo rosa e
marrone giallo rosa e marrone non posso
fare niente purtroppo il limite è 10 che
emozione
mi dispiace davvero io lo dico di chi ha
già partecipato di lasciare per farvi
provare durare ma appunto ci sono
tantissime persone che stanno provando
entrare ora deteriora ora nascondere
perché sarò vi prendiamo subito dice
qualcuno che sta litigando nei commenti
perchè dici chi c'è già chi non s'è già
pronti impostori alcuna soprattutto
[Musica]
[Risate]
mista che anche questa volta a vincere
molto velocemente perché dovete cercare
di nascondervi meglio allora nessuno
prendiamo un evento così siamo più
rapidi ad andare qui è possibile
fruibile
ok ragazzi dovete approfittarne entrare
subito chi ha già partecipato per favore
uscite uscite così gli altri promesso
cari
dobbiamo giocare con lo sconto nodi con
da pastori ok di nuovo imposto
nascondetevi ma scordatevi subito
scoperto che dobbiamo fare e bellissimi
per dire che chi ha promesso detto però
poter stare più attenti al nastro rosa
giallorosso
ok vedo che sono nuove persone questa
partita quindi altri che hanno già
giocato anno hanno lasciato hanno
lasciato spazio agli altri grazie grazie
grazie
nascondetevi però forte per la prossima
si possono diminuire gli impostori da un
uomo deve uscire avventarono mannaggia
perché per il nascondino e meglio
diminuire investitori forze perché
se non vi fosse ok qualcuno ha votato
però non si sa perché forse non aveva
capito come si deve alla prossima però
lo cambiamo in uno die altrimenti sono
troppo veloce
dobbiamo tovaglieri nel codice i codici
lo vedono subito poi non lo so non lo so
se poi un caso che vedo che nasconde ma
bianco sta girando al imposto stato già
pronti vai vi siete nascosti
noi stiamo arrivando da impostori
all'attacco biava
qui non c'è nessuno i vostri con me
[Musica]
report allora praticamente facendo il
report allora scrivi che non si può
votare l'impostore ovviamente non votate
il pastore si deve fare skip però così
voi volete guadagnare tempo per primo
dopo il report c'è tipo 20 secondi in
cui l'impostore non puoi eliminare ok
così io vedo che non avevo il tempo è
anche perché increment devono sbrigarsi
nel fare le snuff adesso è cercare di
completarle prima che noi impostori
troviamo se ti trium eight da sempre
scappare allora quando arriva a zero il
tempo per le chi possiamo partire anche
noi impostare via ma vero che avete
fatto pochissime tac
[Musica]
ok allora io direi di interrompere
questo di cambiare il numero di
impostori in uno no paura che poi si
interrompa la live è stata un disastro
no no dai non rischiamo non rischiamo ok
allora cambiamo cappello che dici come
un cappello colore così magari poi non
siamo più impostori non so perché sta
sempre capitando impostori celeste
questa volta anche se non nessuno di noi
due ceste prof
ok ci sto ancora per un'altra persona
martucci pizza allora si è bloccato a
nome di dieci qua è uscito una pro ha
lavorato ciao luna ok potete entrare
potete entrare anche se ho paura che si
sia bloccato perché nei commenti sta
dicendo che non riuscite a entrare era
successo un'altra volo era un locato a 9
di dieci non si sa il perché in pratica
solo una persona non la fa entrare
non lo so il perché
mi potete dire quando giocate potete
mettere il pubblico
no purtroppo non possiamo vederlo
pubblico perché sono arrivano altre
troppo grosso che non siete voi appunto
arrivano altre persone
chi ha già giocato potete lasciare
qualcuno si è chiamato anita store ora
confonderà tutti purtroppo si è bloccato
a nome di 10 vabbè ma poi dopo la
riavviamo con una lama di euro pronti
due ore allora è vero che si è bloccato
no no si porta di strano che io
finalmente allora era partita normale
normale normale allora dài dài questa
volta dobbiamo far vincere crew match
assolutamente recenti meeting a
nascondino monasteri che la vostro
capito che questo è nascondino scrivi
partita normale partito normale perché
nascondino e solo quando anche noi o no
non mi dire che no no non possiamo no
speriamo che non abbiamo niente altro
ok partito a roma
io faccio finta di niente facciamo le
nostre partite perché volevo vincere
come esseri mezzo scappando dagli stessi
se stesse grazie ma io che non ha capito
non ha capito il gioco
ok noi facciamo nelle nostre tasche
vediamo poi cosa descrivendo nei
commenti perché non fa entrare se sono
nove purtroppo selezione locale ag che
ogni tanto se questo blog
anita non escono le persone
io non rientro controllate assolti portò
adesso ne facciamo una nuova dai adesso
che finiamo questo entrare o farsi
proviamo a farne una nuova se non si
interrompe la interrompe allora non si
no o no c'è un po di confusione con
fusion ora ammette il secondino e solo
quando noi siamo impostori prima perché
lo sentono tutti abbiamo pratica
nascondino e solo quando noi siamo
impostori perché non ha senso giocare
normalmente se voi in live vedete già
che noi siamo impostori vedete chi sono
gli elettori quindi non ha senso
però quando noi non siamo impostori noi
non sappiamo chi sono gli impostori
neanche voi lo sapete quindi è una
partita normale però qualcuno non l'ha
capito e ha subito un altro corpo
riportato allora io già comunque non mi
ricordo mi sono rimaste praticamente
poiché
mista che vinceranno gli impostori
perché non ce la facciamo come nelle
tasche
mannaggia rosa hanno votato io ho
provato il centro mio ragazzo mi
dispiace ma veramente rosa errori posto
c'è prima la vedete quando abbiamo vinto
le premesse propone lo rifacciamo non ha
capito bene ok stiamo creando allora
aspettiamo aspettiamo un momento allora
stiamo creando è il nuovo gioco la live
non si è interrotta a me o no ok
così chi non ha partecipato a farsi
toccare perché a volte le persone non
escono purtroppo quindi bisogna rifare
la partita pesa questa volta proviamo
con un solo impostore così sarà più
difficile e se noi diventiamo impostori
solo se noi diventiamo info storie
giochiamo a nascondino perché altrimenti
voi vedete subito lesioni impostori
artisti quindi solo se noi siamo in tour
story giochiamo a nascondino
a rivelare la partita non rimane che
vero commetto console da the line
patatine fritte dei fronti perché stiamo
per fare conferma pronti vai vai ride by
wire ma ok codice codice cose
ecco il nuovo codice così potete entrare
h e kk di f vi aspettiamo
noi cambiamo colore nel frattempo
rimessi rosa così non vedo nessun
commento con scritto solo grosso cosa
vogliono chiede non è solo in italia ma
era anche la pressione sono c'è fallo
si no campo stiamo dai sì allora merlino
left gay ma come fiera merlini almeno
hai fatto in tempo a vedere in rosa
delle norme sui viola ok vedo che siamo
tutti i nuovi poi anche la prossima
magari faccia una nuova partita così ci
saranno sempre nuove presa 8 abbiamo un
po vediamo ti amo fammi entrare ho visto
un solo che ora anche voi potete
scrivere i commenti chiesto spetto
secondo ora vitale si mette a fare le
tasche o guarda un po
così vediamo secondo voi chi è sospetto
io questo tasto lo riesco a farlo ma
finalmente sono riuscito a entrare non
mi ha fatto entrare purtroppo bisogna
essere veloci
allora smettiamo aiuta c'è qualcuno che
sta nascosto fa sempre paura delle
persone nascoste sembrano impostori loro
abbiamo se tutto a posto qua ma l'audio
del gioco lo sentite ha infatti this is
it riforme l'audio del gioco perché
forse basta si vediamo
allora qua vitale sta facendo le tasche
statisticamente loro pronta per dopo
bene è un uomo passeggiano sintomatico
subito l'ossigeno guastano scrivendo
nomi di uscire le persone
tu piangendo 9 dei casi che ci rimango
male ho sentito sincero non mi fa
entrare audio non lo sentiamo con la
scusa che loro lo mettiamo allora allora
l'audio del gioco dovrebbe essere questo
ok di t systems e adesso si sente meglio
ma lo aumentato troppo per non per non
distruggervi lerici no infatti il caso
mai perché abbiamo fatto una prova prima
con l'asia c'era l'aria di ma ha trovato
il tower scordiamo tutti perché guido
meglio passo meglio più basso
allora qua tutto a posto ancora non mi
fa entrare allora dicono di te i colori
sono felice allora celeste siano safe mi
poteva uccidere tante volte ok quindi
sarebbe evoluto e pari vediamo voi che
secondo voi chi è sospetto che sospetto
andiamo a fare task task ti saluta da
londra wow
[Musica]
dicono che sta vagando sta allargando
voi vedete qualcosa in ritardo sta
vagando di sì spero di no allora dicono
che arancione è sospetto arancione si
infatti non è qui perché non detto
arancione ha detto che celeste safe ma
arancione sospetto hanno già abbassato
le luci ma sentite un rumore strano
qualcuno ha scritto che sente forse la
tastiera qualcuno per vitale siamo
fratelli separati dalla nascita ciao
sono benedetta quindi immagino bene
vista che ti piace mangiare
che cosa ci vedete rosa per un momento
delle ferrovie comparso tutto si sta
allargando di un raga e america che vuol
dire nord europa
abbiamo messo server sbagliato
spero di no spero che la storia la
clausola op
allora io sento bene a meno male o no
grazie alla torta the giocando in europa
non mi sono accorta che server abbiamo
mezzo norme piu europa
non so neanche dove si cambio tra
l'altro nei settaggi del game dopo dopo
ricontrolliamo dopo questa partita
davvero giusto ok allora noi abbiamo
finito le tasche
adesso siamo in un pò a buon punto hanno
detto che il più sospetto sei tu e sai
perché perché non hai fame come siete
benissimo ormai scrive che ci da quanti
anni o mesi si seguite da quanto tempo
siete iscritti da quanto ci seguite mano
sospetto di blu perché li sta all'uomo
visto giallo e blù e poi c'era qualcuno
che è stato fatto fuori secondo me blue
un po sospetto guerra blu spa incolpando
giallo però è rosa ovvero giallo blu sta
incolpando giallo con cui era assieme
più modo blue bay
vediamo non ho fatto in tempo a votarlo
e diamo rosa non era credo ci sono un
impostore
andiamo subito a fare da schio disco blu
e giallo era era proprio dove c'era il
corpo di qualcuno io sono iscritto dal
2017 da un anno e mezzo da due anni
[Musica]
wow cerchio da due anni caspita da un
tacco
[Musica]
io dal primo video da cinque anni
impossibile con i furbetti doppio di due
anni fa o tre anni
caspita dai 500 mila iscritti otto anni
impossibile allora vediamo un po stai
attento blues sembra che mi aiutava
segue fatemeh tasca fate le tasche
mancano poche tasche trio mei così
diciamo iniziare questo bianco qui
giallo si è fatto in tempo chi sospetta
allora dico non è rosa giallo sas nero
giallo io da tre anni io da poco mi
piace moltissimo grazie cari infatti ha
visto da poco in tantissimi stanno
arrivando un sacco di nuovi iscritti
effettivamente sono chi lo merita della
star in famiglia allora blu non era
impostore
è stato eliminato e il giallo giallo ha
sventato giallo terranno tra mutamenti
giallo ai potevo giallo giallo
vediamo 6 giallo giallo nel giallo ok
ciao dice giallo giallo parte ammetto mi
padania dal nuovo codice
allora sì controlliamo anche il server è
giusto che entriamo pronti se non
sbaglio si controlla da qui il server
il nuovo codice per chi vuole
partecipare a sbuffo hard visti arrivare
la fame
se andiamo a mangiare a j
a jsp tutti
[Musica]
mi saluti sono fortunato futura io ti
seguo da un mesetto
vedo che ci sono anche nuovi iscritti
ok nuova partita pronti tranti inizia
via si parte
ma che cos'è e chiumenti fiume allora
dobbiamo cooperare anche assieme a voi
in diretta con noi vediamo i venti si
chiesta allora reactor bianco in seguito
a vitale allora osservate bene tutto tra
l'altro voi siete super super svegli
lo ricordo si deve concentrare anche su
quel mondo lì per lì devi stare lì per
caso
sono quasi fatti sono quasi fatta
l'ultimo lo posso fare
non è stata comunque stavo dicendo che
voi siete super svegli e siete super
attenti a ogni dettaglio ogni
particolare lo so perché noi leggiamo
sempre così come avete visto quella cosa
li avete visto berlino che va già fatto
oppure accaduto quello che è successo
quello che so che a te ti approfitti
dettaglio e anche il gameplay vi
accorgete subito però è molto più
attenti di noi chi è sospetto chi
elimina quando riuscita a scoprire già
nei primi secondi il ritmo store infatti
ha fatto non infatti scrive tc pure qua
nella chat chi è sospetto secondo voi
che noi leggiamo allora di nuovo giallo
dicono sospeso andò il sospetto
io ti seguo da quando facevi il video
della battaglia degli scherzi quindi
proprio tallini dopo tre anni fa io non
riesco a entrare allora vi spiego perché
non vi fa entrare perché se la partita è
già iniziata non si può più entrare
quindi dovete provare a entrare una
volta che noi creiamo la partita e
appare il codice cui dovete prenderlo in
con grillo gioco è iniziare appunto noi
ora stiamo facendo sempre nuovo partita
perché così nuove persone riescono ad
entrare in libia mi hanno fatto
eliminato tra l'altro voi dicevate che
era il giallo il sospetto invece è stato
lì mi noi ti amo vediamo voi chi
sospettava votiamo anche bianco c'è
scritto cambiate server perché europa
larga mettete americi dovete dire qual è
come si faccia una persona arjen dice di
mettere in nord america ok dopo che
facciamo la prossima partita
proviamo a mettere nord america ci
dovete spiegare dove si trova perché non
l'ho trovato
forse nelle impostazioni all'inizio
scrive vi si troverà un programma
nel frattempo allora hanno detto che blu
e lime sono su sas bollenti allora
queste sono le tasche più noioso secondo
me quelle dei ricavi aiuto se qualcuno
che si sta appiccicato noi abbiamo
finito si mette in basso a destra hanno
scritto bazaar d'america bannate quelli
che hanno già giocato nomi di persone
veramente quindi noi facciamo un nuovo
partito che super sospetto che chi
spettano fatto in tempo a leggere
allora arianna dice dovete andare
all'inizio dovete mettere il nome sta in
basso a destra ok perfetto grazie a
qualcuno ha detto chi ex super su questo
aspetto non ha fatto in tempo a leggere
rosso sospetto dico rosso lo dice pure
qua vicino a noi si sta a te non ci
credo sia mo che carini grazie nero
anche nero era tanto che non vedevano
sbucato così davanti all'improvviso
caspita ma se seguite da un sacco di
tempo grazie che sono iscritta da due
anni dopo la cambia non entro mai serve
bloom allora no blu è stato eliminato
quindi non è lui
chi può essere anche celeste dicevano
che sospetto però adesso aspetto dicono
anche rosa noi però non siamo sicuri
forse rosso potrebbe essere nero io voto
nero perché era tanto che non lo vedevo
in giro quindi secondo me n'ero dicono
celeste comunque non ero nessuno nessuno
chi segue da nove mesi benvenuti i nuovi
arrivati
avete lasciato mi piace alzate mi piace
sto tremando come una foglia
un bacione ta nea ora treme rai ancora
di più per
abbiamo detto che sono spaventata quando
entri del gioco in basso a destra
il pallino a destra ok dopo lo facciamo
in modo sport in ora di alloro al nero o
nero non può essere era con noi e forse
la celeste non mi ricordo se celeste mi
stava inseguendo se è uscito dall ieri
secondo me celeste perché céleste anche
in chat e voi dice di certi che diceva
sempre che sarebbe sospetto quindi direi
celeste lo stesso che disse vediamo è
bloccato però no non si scusa allora
votato cielo ti voglio bene
solo lei però scusa sto scherzando
devo da tre anni il rosso sospetto
dicono c'è ancora roma
no sai che era stato lì si farà
rosso dai manca robot che task fate più
dire tac allora ascolta ascolta se nero
e celeste ci stanno seguendo rosso è
entrato qui se lei ero anche un po
strano come si segue le orme loro sono
che anzi mi dispiace pure di averlo
votato sulle stelline vediamo che dicono
assorisp emily cosa dite voi
allora io sono diventata bianco cadavere
per l'ansia dice morgan state che ti è
venuta l'ansia
chi segue da tre anni questo che si
fanno solo dopo la pubblico questa live
così se volete potete rivederla per chi
non ha fatto in tempo a partecipare alla
live può vederla io non avrò mai la
possibilità ho capito e celeste si
stanno nascondendo apposta lidi e
sicuramente luglio nuovamente si stava
nascondendo si era nascosto qui a
seguirlo dobbiamo stupirci e l'est e
rischiamo gup che c'e rimini però sono
tutti qua sul celeste
mi chiamo rosso sta facendo la tasca
facendo finta rosso non si sa se stava
facendo finta sto facendo una task che
dite dai ma lentissimi e allora dico non
se le cose mossa si è mossa la barra
quindi è vero che forse rosso stava
facendo una task nothing in rosso
celeste allora si lesse no e perché ho
visto che si muoveva la barra erano gli
unici due che stavano lì io ero con
anita giuro che non sono io che già 16
di uno che non sono io allora si sono
varie cose sospette che si possono dire
in among us che io stavo facendo
l'italia
[Musica]
quale altro io ero in electric tipo dai
votiamo secondo me sa celeste si questo
non ho fatto in tempo no vediamo non
erano manna scusa celeste per aver
dubitato di chi è allora che le tesi
anche voi chi è
io leggo i vostri commenti nella chat
sto piangendo celeste continuano a dire
cosa nero io pensavo fosse nero
l'impostore tra l'altro ma verde
comincia ad essere un po sospetto adesso
non so chi potrebbe vincere noto rosso
dicono dicono rosso dai fidiamoci di
sono gli schemi l'ipo crediamo secondo
me verde invece che la cosa per sospetto
vediamo
altrimenti vince l'impostore avevo
pensato
non ho ancora siamo in tre perché non è
questa qua no vabbè rischiamo di perdere
sicuro perde perde nord aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto ma dovrebbero non lo so se
che vorrebbe scappare la parola se lo sa
impostare elimina o solo una persona 3
nei due chiamiamo la marcia si meeting
allora rechichi preliminare guarda aiuto
ci segue no secondo me stava per
eliminarsi che facciamo ci buttiamo e il
verde e rosa dicono ma ovviamente sono
gli unici due rimasti di si perde
io dico verde adesso verde il mio dio se
non è lui guarda vediamo ok ok adesso
scopriamo sera l'impostore
[Musica]
rosa sei stata bravissima bravissimi
giocatori veramente bellavista abbiamo
eliminato tutti tranne l'imposto arriva
poveri
allora prossima partita dice ah sì
perché dobbiamo europe quindi dicevano
nord america ok proviamo ok
proviamo con norton e allora aspettiamo
un momento che voi vi mette in posizione
adesso mette risultato le dita
mettetevi in posizione per il codice
pronti via un'impostora abbiamo messo in
nord america allora il codice m y è gpg
fateci sapere se va meglio anche se vedo
che il ping sembra un po più alto vai
cambia il colore in rosa abbiamo pure il
cappello
allora questa è il penultimo partito
perché abbiamo fame dopo bersani
[Musica]
altra descrizione europea pasto tipo
invero stato che ha fatto
le persone che stanno provando ad
entrare che se tipo il caos
vediamo vediamo dai vedo dei nomi dei
nuovi da weber dei nomi nuovi ciao
diretta vediamo un po ok tutto a posto
ci vedete ci vedete è più veloce era
meglio prima
sì infatti dovrebbe essere meglio adesso
abbiamo seguito i vostri consigli
queste ragazze la penultima partita via
la corte 32 più mentre allora mi
raccomando anche voi dovevate vedere
post investigatori investigatori fatti
investigatori stiamo noi questa volta
non possiamo giocare così male come la
scorsa partita che ha vinto l'impostore
mi ha chiesto io li amo stare più
attenti questa la mia tasca preferita io
spero mi devi far finta graham andati a
seguirmi per chi è entrato da poco nella
live tra sfera pubblica una foto e se
avete partecipato alla live scrivete
nella foto il commento scrivete ho
partecipato la live di oggi e io vi
risponderò al commento quindi andate a
seguirmi nome netta stories c'è blu che
si è messo il nostro nato con una frana
abbiamo già vinto che cosa ma forse
l'impostore uscito non me la numero sono
reso conto dai coldplay e game
così è durato troppo poco hanno sì sì
rifacciamo la partita perché è durata
troppo poco almeno potete giocare un po
di più
battisti scusa siamo onorati di dai
dobbiamo scovare questi brutti in
professore è frutto re a me batte forte
il cuore
che carino no io lo odio questo tasca
anch'io la mia è quella che odio di più
a me brontola la pancia ma devi mangiare
dai lavorativa l'ultima partita o no io
qua non ho nessun sospetto però hanno
eliminato nero
non si sa dove ancora mi sospettate
voglio entrare no non è questa l'ultima
beatrice l'opera chirurgo no io schifo
perché non ho abbastanza prove di è vero
non sappiamo ancora no traggo però le
drago ti sei preferenza tramite i talk
grazie
dai dai potuto vediamo vediamo un po io
sospetto ancora vitale nono l'altro poi
all'inizio potete vedere che noi tutti
il reattore
vediamo chi c'è chi non c'è arrivato e
actor vediamo un nuovo stavolta fanno
già fatto ok chi c'era non fa tutto
anche chi non c'è potrebbe essere luxor
e giallo ci sta seguendo
beh effettivamente vediamo
io piango perché non piango io piaccio
fame il progetto allora vai vai vediamo
un po chi arriva qua rosso perché non
sai come lettere anni elisa ok questo è
fatto a renzo ne sa se queste che tasche
non avevo anche perché si aspetta sera
in zone giallo superstar un bene
ci manca solo una tasca a noi precisiamo
che cosa mangiate dicono allora io avrei
volere uno dei miei piatti preferiti
sono gli spaghetti aglio olio e
peperoncino come li fa viva e vitale
bravi lo stiamo avvicinando un bravo
intimissimo e quindi mi sa che si mangia
remo spaghetti aglio olio e peperoncino
cuffia sono un sacco dove allora intero
popolo giallo staff vediamo dice bassi
dai bianco staff
io vi dico sempre di prendere i forni
una tradizione di guardare il video di
vita astori 6 a mettersi comodi e quindi
o nel lettone divano nella sedia dove
volete
i primi ribot scorno la frutta patatino
le verdure quinte nevi scrivete nuovo
che vivi fai sempre in gran parte allora
tra lo staff dicono noi dobbiamo fare
l'ultima tusk
vitale 6 supera anche a ditte grati a
breve un complimento quelli come un voto
il complimento di marmo vetro blu
mettete il nuovo blues ha eliminato cosa
di con una rosa blu dove lo sanno perché
sto mai vedono povera dai hanno votato
tutti i blu cominciamo bravissima
impostare può impostare questa volta è
stato eliminare noi perché ovviamente
poi lo vedono tutti vanno lasciate per
ultimi altri crediamo che fa partita e
passiamo a lui
ultima partita tenetevi pronti tre tipi
pronti ci hanno detto come stava andando
con un nord america sì qualcuno ha detto
che stavo andando un caloroso ma allora
ultimo panormo codice fuori casa fmf pkf
io cambio ricordiamo vi aspettiamo
questa è l'ultima partita e ragazzi
anche perché stiamo in live da uno
[Musica]
per è stato super divertente e bonato il
terzo anche per cui è volato scrivete se
lo voglia giocare con voi
eccoli sono arrivati tutti subito che
l'ultima partita vediamo un po 34 32
ora vediamo vediamo vediamo
problemi vediamo di scoprire fatto
impostori tutti all'inizio del mezzo
scopriamo l'ultimo impostore allora
sempre la nostra card osservate bene dai
dobbiamo riuscire a scoprire l'inferno
ore prima ho sbagliato l'impostore
eliminarsi non gli conviene agli
impostori eliminati perché lo vedono
tutti
io sono entrata non mi fa entrare già si
è volato il tempo io so più davvero non
so perché mai il live vuole il tempo
anch'io quando guardo io le live vuole
il tempo cioè vorrei stare lì a
guardarlo e proprio gatto di tempo
perché mi vuole il tempo qui mi emoziono
anch'io quando faccio le live sia quando
lo guardo mi emoziono angelo fatto
quando fate ancora delle live
lasciate un mi piace questo live
raggiungere i 30 mila mi piacere fare
un'altra la prossima settimana quindi la
strada un bel mi piace
sto leggendo i milioni di commenti che
dicono in tanti scrivete che non vi fa
entrare perché è passata un'ora il tempo
dieci stelle
ok allora concentriamoci concentriamoci
che succeda niente avevo visto un
movimento sospetto
ho visto il corpo che cadeva e celeste
che scappava
sono sicura che sia celeste eccellenze
scrivete ste se celeste ha sbagliato a
eliminare davanti a minuti
noi votiamo ce ne uscì adesso c'è
scritto non era un'impostora si no
c'erano due mi sembra che fosse celeste
viola forze che stanno viola è stato
eliminato
sarà un blu secondo me la ragione sta
[Musica]
troppo divertente giocare con voi ora
leggiamo un momento la chat
però questa era l'ultima partita quindi
se volete dirci qualcosa scrivere sera
ora nella chat così leggiamo qualcosa
qualcosina e poi si salutiamo così
andiamo a vantare però poi noi leggeremo
i commenti in questa live quindi se
volete comunque dirci qual cosa scrivete
giorno se volete iscriversi qual era il
vostro momento preferito il momento più
divertente scrivetecelo nei commenti o
poi li leggo mi mette cuoricini di
rispondono se volete inviato meno
ricetta dei biscotti al cioccolato
possibilmente dappertutto nella slot
state scrivendo purtroppo non mi ha
fatto entrare allora la prossima volta
ci sarà la possibilità anche per chi non
è riuscita è troppo solo nove persone
alla volta possono entrare oltre a noi e
quindi 10 in totale
voi siete tantissimi però veramente è
stato troppo divertente giocare
ma il fatto di giocare log sono
prelevate sempre è stato super
divertente
vorremmo quindi lasciate un bel mi piace
è così
il video raggiunge 30 mila mi piace ne
faremo un altro
seguitemi su instagram seguiti vissuti
ict hoc ora se volete andate a vedere il
nuovo video in cui abbiamo giocato ieri
stringere si è troppo divertente perché
fanno titanic assieme a vederla e noi
ora finora l'aiuto di dio anche noi
aumentare che io posso dire seguirmi in
cucina se avete vissuto in tags
instagram ed eseguiti in cucina ma poi
ci leggiamo tutti i commenti alla live
quindi se volete rivederla o se volete
dirsi appunto i momenti più divertenti
scriveteci di tutti ciao ciao
[Musica]